well churches were closed across America
but Planned Parenthood clinics stayed
open thanks to the politicians they paid
off abortions were critical
infrastructure in the view of so many
governors Gretchen Whitmer made that
point explicitly despite that advantage
they enjoyed over legitimate businesses
despite the fact the National
Organization of planned parent has
thousands of employees Planned
Parenthood affiliates still collected
eighty million dollars from the federal
government money that was meant to
assist small businesses he first heard
about that on this show two nights ago
now 27 Republican senators have asked
the Department of Justice to investigate
why that money was sent to Planned
Parenthood in the first place meanwhile
an interview last week Planned
Parenthood CEO was celebrated the silver
lining of the coronavirus not only the
old dying but so are the young thanks to
more telemedicine abortions medication
abortion is is offered earlier in the in
the gestational period and and it really
requires just two pills that that the
person seeking abortion would take
within a 24 hour period in many cases
we're able to do see a patient now with
the expansion of telehealth the via
Skype like this intake the patient and
then drive and that patient will come
and pick up the the prescription and go
home and take that that medication
safely at home it is actually silver
lining in this in this pandemic silver
lining just when you thought our
professional class couldn't get more
ghoulish or anti-human they do Katie
Pavlich is an editor at town hall happy
to have her on tonight okay thanks so
much for coming on how do you think
Planned Parenthood which again takes
hundreds of millions of dollars from
taxpayers every year it's the largest
get-out-the-vote operation the Democrats
have how were they posing as a small
business and getting away with it well
Tucker not only do they get five hundred
million plus dollars from taxpayers
every year they also have six hundred
million plus dollars that come in from
private donations every year two billion
dollars in assets and two billion
dollars in revenue with hundreds of
millions of dollars left over
for things like this and when you look
at the details of these these affiliates
dozens of them who have applied for this
this small business funding the the the
main umbrella organization of Planned
Parenthood is saying well we didn't
apply as a big organization but these
smaller organizations that are
affiliated with us applied because they
should be eligible given the small
number of employees and so that's the
way that they are justifying it and the
vice-president of governmental affairs
is saying that the SBA which is asking
these affiliates to give the money back
that they should that this is an
unrelenting attack on abortion rights
but they also argue this affiliates that
the money was being used to save
employee paychecks well if it was about
saving employee paychecks and why is she
making the argument that this is an
attack on abortion rights well that's a
very good point but this so what you're
saying is it would be like if the Apple
store in Georgetown or midtown Manhattan
applied for a small business loan on the
grounds they're a small business because
they only have 80 employees right right
but then you know that the Apple
headquarters in California did not apply
because they have thousands of employees
and lots of resources but the Planned
Parenthood Action Fund came out with a
statement early on when the cares Act
was first passed that said plan parent
is not does not eligible for this so the
question that the Senators have for the
Justice Department to look into is
whether these applications were made in
a valid non-fraudulent way why is it
that some affiliates under the Planned
Parenthood who should be receiving
plenty of money from this massive
organization we're getting taxpayer
money and will they be forced to give it
back given the vast majority of
resources that they have well that's
that's exactly right it does sound like
fraud I agree with you on that Katie
Pavlich thank you for that
good to see you checker